we were told it was essential to stop
the spread of coronavirus now the
government's abandoned its bespoke
contact tracing app in favour of
technology Google and Apple it's a major
u10 although he said it was for the best
I want to be upfront and open about the
challenges that we and other countries
are facing so we've agreed to join
forces with Google and Apple to bring
the best bits of both systems together
Matt Hancock said developers discovered
problems during testing experts said we
warned you right at the beginning all
together it was a it's a disaster that
many other countries have really plowed
ahead have created were apps that
appeared to be working and being
downloaded and even working across
borders without the UK being at the
table for those discussions they dismiss
people and said that they would have a
better a better up and they said would
have a world-beating system by the
beginning of June of course that's what
we were promised I think most of us just
want a simple virus baiting system all
tracy's perhaps work like this
they tell your mobile phone to share its
details with any other phone that comes
in to potentially dangerous proximity
that list of contacts can then be shared
if the phone's owner becomes ill the
problem the government is encountered is
their preferred system works fairly well
with Google phones but not with Apple's
the government's app picked up 75% of
nearby androids but only 4% of nearby
iPhones
by contrast the Google Apple system
picked up 99% of all phones why well
there are technical reasons but the
bottom line is this it's their system
and they make the rules
the app was being tested on the Isle of
Wight when news of the switch didn't
come as a surprise to disillusioned
residents the island was very much
behind the idea seemed you know the Isle
of Wight is a sort of petri dish for
experimentation many people didn't think
the app worked some people complained of
battery usage being high and slowly
slowly he started to delete the app the
new system has been promoted as being
more privacy focused but it will give
epidemiologists access to less data and
with no date for its arrival it's still
unclear if we'll ever get the
technological protection that we were
told was so essential role amantha Sky
News